talking of air pumped up you get to wear
the suit yeah which is a nice you know
kind of like I'm wearing a suit yeah
well it's not like a big red body condom
but Josh like but it's really you that
like hey it's just of people that get
that thing on I've always like so
terrified I like throw up in the mask or
something like these weird scratches
that you just ya know nothing there's
nothing that can't there's no space in
that thing at all when I put it on I can
actually taste my own genitals it's the
same they roll you in towel or something
I do
that's just at home for my wife smell of
lavender
you know there's something about him
that he uses that he's worked out even
though he has a suit on and all that
when I went and did Avengers you know I
saw those guys put on suits and I saw
underneath like I was like you're not
working out at all suits and they looked
fantastic yeah amazing
whereas him his suit doesn't really have
any bumps and stuff that's not there so
I know that he's back in his thing
because he's kind of like the Daniel
day-lewis of comedians you know I'm
saying very method whereas me as a 50
year old man who gets sore I put myself
through torture for you I know it's
crazy and what was nice was you kept
your fans up to date you posted videos
of your of your workouts it is one of
the videos of you working out
[Applause]
I had know that he had know for sure you
did because it was very indirect you
were in that bathroom admitted I was I
filmed it
[Music]
you